Good afternoon and welcome, everyone. My name is Jeevan Puthenvedu.
I'm an acting cross-disciplinary team lead for the Thoracic and Head Neck Cancers
team within the Office of Oncologic Diseases at
CDER at the FDA, and I co-lead the Oncology Center of Excellence's
Oncology AI program.
I will be moderating today's Code Meets Cure: Navigating the Regulatory
Landscape of AI in Oncology Drug Development session.
We are at an inflection point. Artificial intelligence and machine learning are
no longer theoretical tools on the horizon of oncology drug development.
They are here,
embedded in regulatory submissions, clinical trial designs, diagnostic
platforms, and biomarker discovery pipelines.
The two centers of the FDA focus on drug and biological product developments.
The Center for Drug Evaluation and Research and the Center for Biologics
Evaluation and Research have received well over 1,500 regulatory
submissions incorporating AI in the last 10 years,
with oncology representing the single largest therapeutic area.
The number is accelerating,
but the pace of technological adoption has outrun our shared
framework for evaluating it. Clinicians, data scientists,
regulators, and industry sponsors are all asking versions of the
same fundamental questions. How do we know when we can trust an AI model,
and what does that trust need to be built on?
That is the question this session is designed to explore.
Today's session brings together perspectives from FDA, industry,
and the academic research community to examine the regulatory science and policy
landscape for AI in oncology.
We will hear the experts at the intersection of integrating AI and data science
into cancer research, AI deployment in clinical trials
and other cancer drug development, and regulatory review.
And then we will open up for a structured discussion that I hope will be genuinely
generative, not just a recitation of what we already
know, but a working conversation about where the field needs to go
and questions that need to be answered.
By the end of this 90-minute session, I hope each of you leaves with a clearer
sense of what regulatory grade AI means in practice, that is, what
FDA's current frameworks require, where gaps remain, and most
importantly, how the patient research and clinical communities and
regulators can collaborate to accelerate responsible adoption of these tools.
Before we get started, a few logistics.
If it's okay with everyone, I'd love to keep things informal and refer to everyone
by their first name, especially during the panel discussion.
We'll start off with three brief presentations to help
set the stage for our discussion, first with Dr.
Jeffrey Leake from Fred Hutch, then from George
Hayes-Filio from AstraZeneca. After that, I will give
a talk about the FDA frameworks for use of AI in drug and
biological product development.
Then we'll invite our panelists to introduce themselves, followed by
discussions. So let's begin with our presentation.
Each speaker will have approximately 12 to 15 minutes, and I'll ask
the audience to hold questions, as well as the panelists to hold their questions
until our panel discussion, which should begin around 1:20.
So I'd like to actually invite Dr. Jeff Leake to go ahead.
And when you guys each start your presentation, just give a brief introduction of
who you are and your role in this space.
Great.
Thank you. Thanks very much. And thanks very much for organizing, both
Brad and Jeevan, and everyone else for being here.
And so I'll give a little bit more background on myself, but I
have two roles. I'm at the Fred Hutchinson Cancer Center, and I'm also at this
startup company that spun out called Synthesize Bio.
And the title of my presentation is What Do We Do Now That We've Machine Learned
Everything? And
I think one of the things that's really interesting to me in these kind of dual
roles that I have is seeing a very high-level overview of
how AI is impacting everything from clinical care to clinical
research to clinical drug development.
So I'll do the usual disclosures, mostly related to Synthesize
and also related to some work that I did on Coursera a while ago.
So the two perspectives I'm bringing here, at the Fred Hutch, I'm the chief data
officer and am responsible for sort of the data strategy and has now
also
taken on more and more of the AI strategy at the Fred Hutch,
and then also a professor there. And then at Synthesize Bio, I'm a
co-founder and a board member of that company, which is building generative
models that are going to be used in drug development.
And so from both of these perspectives, I'm going to talk a little bit about where
I see things, and particularly from the academic perspective.
One of the things that I find really useful when talking about...
AI means a lot of different things to a lot of different people, and because it's
such a hot topic and everybody wants to get their arms around it,
everybody's going to define it a little bit differently.
For me, personally,
it makes it a lot easier when I think especially about regulation, if I break AI
into three components. It's a training data set that you put together, and
that might be something that you have locally, it might be something that you're
collaborating with. There's an algorithm that is applied to that data set, whether
it's a supervised learning, supervised machine learning algorithm, or something
generative like an LLM. And then there's an interface that allows you
to interact with that model. And so those are the kind of the three components, and
I find it's easier to kind of talk about it when I think of it as those three
parts. The kind of classic example these days is take all the text on the
internet, stuff it into a transformer model, and then give some people access to a
chatbot.
The reason why this is, of course, a topic that has had a lot of attention at this
AACR is two things are happening simultaneously.
You can scale up the size of compute that is happening, and the kind of scale of
models that you can build is dramatically increasing.
We were just talking before that they keep saying there's going to be a plateau on
these models, and there's no plateau. It just keeps going and going and going.
And at the same time, the collection of different types of data is
getting cheaper and cheaper, and so we're collecting more and more of it.
This is the plot for genomics, but you can make the same exact graph for imaging or
EHR data or really any other type of data.
It's all down and to the right in terms of the cost of collecting
data.I think most importantly, though, is the interface.
Machine learning has been going on for a long time.
There have been these models for a long time.
I think that there's been a lot of innovation in how we interact with these models,
whether it's something like a very general-purpose chatbot like Claude, something
that's a little bit more bio-specific or health-specific, like OpenEvidence,
or like the models that we build at the Synthesize Bio company that are foundation
models for gene expression. All of these have very simple interfaces.
You type in some text, it generates something back for you, and being able to
interact with models is what I think is really driving a lot of the conversation
that's happening.
So I think there's actually... This should say four, so sorry about that.
Already can't count. Four grand opportunities in AI for cancer.
One is in care and operations, one is in drug discovery, one is in drug
development, and one is in consumer health, and I think in all of these areas in
these two roles, particularly in my role as chief data officer and professor,
we're seeing impacts of AI across all of these and kind
of racing to catch up with how we think about regulating them or setting up
frameworks to being able to regulate them.
I'm going to briefly touch on all four.
Just since I'm first, I
decided to zoom out and give a little bit of an overview, and then there'll be
deeper dives on sort of drug development
and discovery on the next couple of talks.
In optimizing care and operations, this is where actually I think AI's had the most
immediate and dramatic impact in the health system.
And largely, that's because a lot of the things that you do there have
different kinds of regulatory structures.
Despite that, it's a really challenging space if you're a chief data officer or
chief AI officer of a healthcare org right now.
You're trying to evaluate how is the data that you are dealing with
from your health system being used or not used in the tools you're interacting
with.
How do you decide which models to deploy,
both for drug development but also just for clinical operations?
And then how do you actually monitor and govern how those models are being used
in practice? So to give you a really concrete example, you can think
about the ways in which ambient listening is being deployed in
clinical care right now. You have companies that offer services where they
basically listen to the patient-doctor interaction, do voice-to-text,
text to various different other things, and those are relatively
lightly regulated. And so the question is: how do you think about, is this okay?
Is it not okay?
Does it feel like it's violating legal requirements?
Is all pretty gray and a little fuzzy and a little bit hard to deal with.
So in this area, it's a little bit less clear.
The other one that I think is really interesting because there's been a lot of
excitement recently. I don't know if people saw this, but a person
using large language models and their own personal
resources had diagnosed the cancer of their dog.
I don't know if any of you saw this announcement.
And then they actually did some experiments and then
basically tried to cure their own dog of cancer from using LLMs and were quite
successful, according to all the press around this story.
But this is where,
that's in dogs, but you could imagine that kind of thing is the
potential of these models in humans, too.
And so we have to really think through what does it mean to regulate drug discovery
if anybody can do it. And so I think that it's a really important
gap in how we think about how these things are regulated.
Because, if that person's
dog had died, that's of course tragic.
But if people start saying, "I've discovered a new drug for something," and then it
gets deployed to a lot of humans, that could be even more importantly
challenging.
In drug development, I think that there's actually a split, and I'll let
others talk a lot more about this who have more experience in the area.
But my personal experience in it is there's a real split between supervised and
generative models. For supervised models, I actually feel like the
regulatory pathway is pretty well...
There's still work to be done, but there's a lot of development that's been put in
place. For generative models, it's much more unclear how you
regulate how a generative model is going to work.
And what I mean by that is if that model isn't just doing a specific task but
has a broad collection of use cases, understanding how does
that model work for those specific use cases?
How do you put a barrier around those use cases and then regulate
that? Is something that I think is a pretty tricky problem, and although
there's really great guidance that has been coming out, and draft guidance that's
been coming out from the FDA, some of that kind of is a little bit more challenging
when you get to the sort of generative components of these models.
And then the last one that we're seeing a lot of is, there was a time
where there was Dr. Google. You came in to see your provider, and you asked
Google questions about your health.
Dr. GPT is now the thing, and so people come in, and they have already
talked to Claude or a GPT model or
Google Gemini or one of these other models, and they've asked a lot of questions.
And they've uploaded their whole patient record to this modeling system.
Sometimes it provides really great information.
Sometimes it provides a lot of comfort to patients who can't get access to health
providers as much as they would like.
At the same time, there can also be pretty tragic consequences if they get
misinformation or that information isn't completely well-characterized.
And so in this space, and I think in all of the spaces,
we don't really fully understand what is the surface of
where these models work very well and where these models don't work very well, and
that difference can be critical for using these
models in practice. And so I think these are four areas where I
think my personal belief is that AI will have major
impacts on all four of these areas and major positive impacts, but there are
some challenges that remain in how do we regulate them.
And I think for somebody who has to set an AI strategy for a whole healthcare
org that includes clinical trials and includes healthcare, it includes research,
the really challenging thing is that the AI regulatory environment is a bit
uneven. In some places, it's extremely mature. It's really been...
And of course, this is one person's opinion.
I'm not representing the opinion of the Fred Hutch or Synthesize Bio in stating
whether something's emerging or not. This is Jeff Leek's opinion.
There are some areas where it feels like the regulation is very clear, and you can
really use it, and that means you can move really, really quickly.
And then there are other places where it's pretty unclear, and it's still being
developed, and it means it's much harder to move quickly.
And so the challenge, I think, for all of us is that these models are
developing at a speed that makes it really hard to
know how to evaluate them and make good decisions about
them.So, a couple of opportunities I think we can
fill collaboratively at the intersection of industry, academics,
and government are four areas. One is these
models are going to become more complicated, and I'm stealing a little thunder
here. This is actually George's idea.
He's going to talk a lot more about this, but I'm going to say that I agree that
benchmarks are an incredibly important component of this.
Like, the models are going to get more complicated, so we can't rely on
them being interpretable. Like, if you have a trillion-parameter model, you're
never going to be able to interpret it. So how do you evaluate it?
How do you tell if it's going to do the right thing or not?
And then the other thing is these benchmarks have to evolve over time because
basically, week to week, there's a new capability you didn't even know about.
And if
the benchmarks aren't keeping pace, we can't tell what's going to happen with them.
Consumers are going to use these models for their own healthcare, but also for even
drug development, et cetera. We have to think about how we both
evaluate them and communicate that.
And I think there's this commoditization of biomedical science
revolution that's coming at us, that's a little shocking how fast
it's coming at us, where to do drug discovery and drug
development today requires massive upfront investments in
laboratories and patient access and clinical trial
infrastructure, et cetera. And increasingly, as these generative
models get better and better, components of that will be doable by
people in their garage, so to speak.
And so I think that this sort of garage band version of
biomedical startup space is going to really start to hit in the next couple of
years.
And then last is ensuring representation in models.
So a lot of the training data are heavily focused on people from a
particular ancestry, people from a particular sort of financial strata, et
cetera. And so how do we actually really build models that represent us
collectively as people? This is incredibly important, especially if you're
deploying a model that you trained at Fred Hutch, and you want to deploy it in a
community health clinic in Idaho, where I grew up, or in Baltimore,
where I worked before. That model might not work at all if you only use the
Seattle data to represent it. And so really thinking about how do we build and
evaluate models across broader, more representative populations is going to be
really critical. So at a high level, I think that there's huge
opportunities in this space. I'm unbelievably excited about it,
and I think we have to rethink a little bit how we interact with models
as they become more complicated, but also more powerful and most importantly,
more available to more people so that power gets put in more and more people's
hands.
And that's it.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Jeff.
Great
talk. Kind of
creating a definition of AI and then the framework of these four arenas where
AI potentially has huge possibilities for
impact.
I'm going to invite now George to come up and
give a brief introduction and then go ahead with your talk. Thank you.
Thank you so much. Such a privilege to be here with you today.
I'm George Visfilo. I'm the chief
of AI for science innovation at AstraZeneca.
I am afraid to say that unlike Jeff here, I'm not a
computer scientist or a computational biologist. I'm a pathologist by training.
So why
would a pathologist be here with you talking about
AI
and regulation in the R&D space in pharma?
I actually have had the
privilege of witnessing and being
involved in the very transformation of what we can do in pathology
through AI, not with AI, reimagining
pathology from first principles.
And actually, we have been
really privileged to have had the first Class 2 FDA
clearance of an AI applied to pathology in
partnership with our friends from MSK back in
2021, September.
It's super exciting. Now with the company I work
for, we have also had a breakthrough device designation for the first
predictive biomarker for an antibody drug
conjugate through AI,
which is applied to pathology. It's extremely exciting.
But here are my conflicts of interest.
I would submit
that
AI is going to fundamentally change every step of what we
do in pharma,
from accelerating drug discovery to transforming clinical development,
optimizing clinical operations, and delivering patients' journeys that
are more impactful,
meaningful, and more seamless. That's the hypothesis here.
And the pace of development... And I switched off the slides so
that we can actually discuss this together here, connect with this
idea. We have moved from
extremely curated tabular datasets that were needed for us to
develop the machine learning solutions, to using raw data in a
multimodal way. And actually, at this meeting, we saw the Apollo model
presented at the presidential symposium yesterday at the
plenary. Sorry, the plenary session.
Faisal Mahmood shipped the first
virtual patient representation, 18 data modalities, with
all the modalities integrated in a single vector per patient.
Can you just conceive that? How fast we're moving?
And
at the frontier level, we have got to the
automated alignment researchers.
Meaning that the models can start training the
models themselves and get into what they label now as
alien research because it goes above and beyond our comprehension.
The nonlinear correlations in the latent space derive new knowledge.
So it's coming extremely fast.
I think we have allGot to accept that.
And as Jeff said, if we're thinking about supervised models, we
have a really clear path towards regulatory approvals, how we
deploy. But these highly capable models that are
domain-specific and coming into biomedical research, they're becoming
a reality. So with that in mind, let's get to the talk then, shall
we?
Stop with the doom and gloom for a second. Let's just focus here.
So if you accept that the pace of innovation is incredibly high, things are
moving really, really fast,
in that AI is transforming everything that we do in research and
development. I think the question here is how do we deliver
fit-for-purpose solutions in really in a meaningful way to
benefit who matters the most, the patients?
Have to remember that behind any
biomedical discovery that we make, there's a patient waiting for the
right diagnosis, the right treatment, the right biomarker,
the right time to receive that treatment during their therapeutic
journeys.
This is actually what
we're seeking to change, to improve, to transform in a positive way.
So firstly, I would submit that there are three questions that we need collectively
to address. First, who builds, who governs, and who creates
trust? And trust is a very important word when it comes to AI
development. Who creates trust across all the different fields
involved when it comes to the development of these
solutions in the context of novel therapeutics in
pharma?
It's really complex. Second, how to create the
guardrails. As Jeff said, we should not create bottlenecks for the
development. We need to create guardrails, clear guardrails for these
most capable models so we can deploy them in a way that's safe,
responsible, but we can still derive the innovation.
Because if we put bottlenecks, we're just going to slow innovation without
delivering transformational outcomes. So we need to find that balance.
But for us to get to the guardrails, there's a super important point here.
We need to understand then the evaluations and benchmarks that we
subject these models to. But
it's not only that. The process, even if we get all the datasets to do the
evaluations and benchmarks really precisely,
you can still gamify the system. You can game the system and get really great
performance with the models if the
SOPs for the benchmarking are not agreed upon.
So we really need an honest broker, a third party,
someone who is not directly involved in the development of those models
for us to evaluate and benchmark them adequately.
I have to say that
approval of AI solutions, as Jeff was mentioning in his talk, actually
are happening. Those approvals are happening in the radiology space.
There are many that have taken place, and even in pathology.
Look, we have approvals already from the perspective of de
novo approvals, PMAs or 510s. That
have happened over the last decade.
Exactly the last decade.
So it's not that the regulators are,
let's say,
unfamiliar with these approvals.
The fact of the matter is that even though we have the approvals
and the solutions are available, and in some places there is the infrastructure to
deploy them, the adoption has been quite limited,
particularly in pathology. It's super interesting, isn't it?
We have information that goes above and beyond what we pathologists, people like
me, can provide,
yet the adoption is quite limited.
I would submit that one of the challenges there is that we
did not understand exactly what the users
here would need. And I have to give kudos to Jacob
Carter, who is here in the audience, because he actually went back
and asked, what if we approach the users here, the
medical oncologists, the clinicians who will be deploying the solutions to make
critical decisions about patients?
What would they need to see in terms of a framework to be able
to understand whether an AI solution is applicable or not,
is actually valid or not? And this is a fantastic framework.
Jacob,
please jump in if I say something that's not correct here, but this
led to the engagement with multiple experts in the field,
multiple Delphi consensus
approaches, and then eventually three classes of
AI-driven biomarkers. Class A, where
basically we are just replicating a task
that pathologists can do today.
And here, the validation is technical validation and showing
the concordance really well.
Then class B is when we started inferring from the
pathology image something else. Imagine going
and
establishing a different biomarker that requires above and beyond the
pathology itself. You infer from the H&E.
And here, the validation requires then
validation with the gold standard.
Imagine predicting an EGFR mutation, then you validate against the gold
standard. But what I find most exciting is class C,
that actually we're predicting outcomes, either
prognostication,
C1, or prediction of therapeutic response,
then C2.
Importantly here, there were two key messages
that we understood from the experts then.
First, that for C2,
validation with a prospective trial is required.
So that conclusion that I took, I was not involved in this, but I
took is that just because we are leveraging these fantastic transformational
technologies, we do not have a poetic license to bypass the
idea of levels of evidence, what's required for clinical utility.
That's one conclusion. The second that was really well
articulated in the guidelines, the eBay
guidelines... is that
explainability may not be required, but validation with fit
for purpose in sufficiently powered cohorts is.
That validation, we need to go the extra mile and deliver it for us
to be able to trust the AI solution.
And I find this incredibly important that we are moving away from that
requirement for explainability or interpretability for one reason.
If we're leveraging those nonlinear correlations that the models offer,
it's really hard to translate them into semantics
that are easily understandable. And if we do that, if we go back to
that requirement, we may be limiting the very performance of the models that we're
developing. And as Jeff said, if you get to a trillion-parameter model,
we will have trouble converting that into words. Yeah?
So what I would submit here
is that for us
to get that, to a point where we can then start
incorporating the solutions into the ways
we deliver biomarkers and novel treatments for patients,
we'll have to move away from that idea of the regulators
providing bottlenecks to a point where we can have guardrails,
say, in this particular context, you can deploy these solutions safely
and benefit the patients.
For us to do that, we actually have to
accept that an ecosystem of partnerships will be sine qua
non. There's no other way for us to do it, because no
partner understands all the intricate complexities for the
different steps required, would have all the data, all the
approaches, all the technology. So bringing together
academia, where many of the solutions are developed, industry,
the payers,
and the regulators, but having one important point,
patient at the very center of this innovation-driven
ecosystem.
And when we do that, we'll be well on our way
towards delivering the solutions to patients through our
rather arcane medical systems, through our
incredibly matrixed
R&D in pharma
divisions.
But without that ecosystem of partnerships, it's going to be
extremely challenging for us to deliver solutions that are really fit for their
purpose. And we have to collaborate to set the bar to
define the correct evaluation, the correct benchmarks, the correct
approaches to do that. And I'm really incredibly encouraged that the
NCI is taking the lead here, and they are commissioning a
workshop for us to address these evaluations and benchmarks
from first principles. Let's not compromise.
Let's create this, have the right data set.
Let's start asking the questions in how we understand
the solutions that are highly performant and fit for their
purpose. Because the last thing that we would like to happen is that we end
up in a Wild West version of biomarkers driven
by AI in oncology.
Second point,
we have to define again, what is
the
definition of an impactful solution within a given
context for a given patient population?
The third that I would submit here, that the levels of evidence need to be
extremely high.
Again, just because we're using fancy technology, we should not
be short cutting here or cutting any corners in terms of the levels of
evidence needed. We have to work together to generate those levels of
evidence. And with that thought,
I am a firm believer here that if we work together,
create this ecosystem, we'll be able to deliver our bold
ambition in oncology. That's eventually to eliminate cancer as a cause of
death. It's not going to magically happen.
It will require a lot of effort from all of us in actually
reimagining our roles if we consider ourselves
part of this ecosystem, not as individual players.
With that request for collaboration, partnership,
both in terms of thought and execution, I'd like to thank you again for your
attention. I would happily take any questions you might have. Thank you.
Great. Thank you so much, Jorge. I appreciate that.
Really laying out some of these questions that we should be asking ourselves,
especially as we try to move forward as collaborators.
And I appreciate that you want to maintain those high levels of evidence, which are
really necessary. So, in my presentation, I'm going to
give FDA's current thinking on how we approach the
regulation of artificial intelligence in cancer drug development, what our
framework looks like
as it stands right now, what we're asking for sponsors, and where the field needs
to go. I'll try to be practical and specific because I know this audience
is working on these questions in real time.
So AI is being used across every phase of the drug product life cycle, and the
breadth is part of what makes the regulation both exciting and
challenging. In the drug discovery phase, AI is being
used for drug target identification, compound screening, molecular
design. In the non-clinical research, we're seeing AI applied to
pharmacokinetics and pharmacodynamics modeling and toxicology studies.
In clinical research, AI is being used for dose finding, site
selection,
patient recruitment and retention,
data collection and management, real world data analyses, patient
recruitment, and clinical endpoint assessment.
And in the manufacturing and post-marketing setting,
we're looking at surveillance. AI is being
applied to dose optimization and pharmacovigilance as well.
I want to clarify one important scoping point, and it's kind of been brought up a
little bit. FDA's perspective on AI for drugs and
biologicsWhich was shown in this January
2025 draft guidance, which I'll explore in more detail.
It's focused specifically on AI used to produce data and information
to support regulatory decision-making regarding safety,
effectiveness, and quality for drugs.
It explicitly does not cover drug discovery, and it does not cover
purely operational uses of AI, such as drafting a regulatory
submission or allocating internal resources.
And so those things don't affect the patient safety or study reliability, so
that's not so much of a concern for us at the FDA.
So our regulatory approach isn't theoretical.
It's grounded in real experience reviewing AI regulatory submissions.
Through 2024, CDER's received 800 submissions that include
AI, and when you add in CBER, that number exceeds over 1,000.
The growth has been dramatic.
It started as a handful of submissions annually before
2021 to 307 in 2024 alone.
And oncology consistently represents the largest share of AI-containing
submissions across the therapeutic areas at about 27% of the total.
The use cases we're seeing are diverse.
In oncology specifically, they include patient selection and outcome prediction,
confounding adjustment, pharmacometric modeling, use of external control
arms, and post-marketing surveillance using natural language processing.
The breadth of the applications is exactly why we need a framework flexible
enough to accommodate very different types of AI use.
Our framework also didn't emerge in isolation.
It was shaped by years of collaborative engagement, workshops, expert
convenings,
the establishment of an AI council, policy working group, community of practice,
and interest groups within FDA, and ongoing tracking of AI
uses in regulatory submissions.
All of that culminated in the publication of draft guidance documents in January
2025.
So for this draft guidance, considerations for the use
of artificial intelligence to support regulatory decision-making for drug and
biologics products,
it's organized around three main areas.
Risk-based credibility assessment framework, special considerations for
lifecycle maintenance of AI model credibility, and
options for early engagement with the agency.
So to make the framework concrete, I'm going
to walk through an example, and this one is directly relevant to oncology.
And this is actually the first example that's provided within the draft guidance.
Drug A is under development and is associated with a life-threatening
drug-related adverse event. In previous trials, all
patients underwent 24 hours of inpatient monitoring after
dosing because of concerns of this potential reaction.
But data from those trials showed that some patients were actually at low risk.
In a new study, the sponsor wants to use an AI model to identify which
patients are at low risk and send those participants
home for outpatient monitoring instead of keeping them in the inpatient setting.
This is a realistic scenario in oncology, where toxicity management is central to
trial design and where the stakes of misclassification are high.
I'll use this example to walk through our framework.
So the framework consists of seven steps.
Let me walk through the first three using our example, then I'll describe the
remaining steps more briefly.
Step one is to define the question of interest.
The specific question, decision, or concern the AI model is being used to
address. In our example, the question is: What participants can be
considered low risk and do not need inpatient monitoring after
dosing?
Step two is to define the context of use.
The context of use describes the specific role and scope of the AI model.
In this case, the COU is using the AI
model to predict a patient's risk for a potentially
life-threatening adverse event to drug A based on baseline
characteristics and lab values. The model will stratify the clinical
trial participants or patients into low versus high-risk
groups and will be the sole determinant of whether patients require inpatient or
outpatient monitoring after dosing.
Step three is to assess the model risk, which is the conceptual heart of the
framework, and so I'll spend a little bit of time here.
So model risk is the possibility that the AI model output may lead to
an incorrect decision that could result in an adverse outcome.
Importantly, it is not the risk intrinsic to the model.
Model risk is defined by two independently determined factors,
model influence and decision consequence.
Model influence, which is shown across the x-axis, is the contribution
of AI model's output relative to other evidence used to
answer the question of interest. In our example, the AI model is the sole
determinant of which type of monitoring a patient receives.
There's no other evidence being used in parallel.
So in this example, the model influence is high.
Decision consequence, which is shown along the y-axis, is the
significance of an adverse outcome if the AI model gets it wrong.
If patients who actually need inpatient monitoring are misclassified as low
risk and sent home, they could experience a life-threatening adverse
reaction without access to appropriate treatment.
Decision consequence is high.
Therefore, the model risk for this COU is high, and that matters because
the level and stringency of credibility evidence, which is the
purposes of step four through seven, is calibrated to that risk
level.
One thing to consider is that humans in the loops could help moderate this risk.
What we ask for in terms of this credibility evidence is
commensurate with model risk and tailored to the specific context of
use. For a high-risk model, we'll ask for greater
oversight,
more stringent performance acceptance criteria, more detailed
documentation, more rigorous credibility assessment activities,
and more robust risk mitigation strategies.
For a low-risk modelSay an AI tool used to flag potential
data entry errors in a clinical database where a human reviews
every flag, we would likely ask for much less.
One thing to note, this isn't a one-size-fits-all framework.
It's designed to be proportionate, and that proportionality is what makes it
applicable across the enormous diversity of AI uses we are and will
continue to see in oncology submissions.
Continuing through the rest of the steps, step four is to develop a
credibility assessment plan. So this plan describes how you establish that the
AI model output is credible for the specific
COU. It should describe the model itself, the data used to develop it, and
how the model was trained and evaluated.
Critically, this is actually the step where we strongly encourage sponsors to come
in to talk to us. Early engagement with the FDA before a sponsor
executes a plan can save significant time and resources by aligning
expectations up front. Step five is then to execute the plan, and this
is ideally before that early engagement.
Step six is to document the results in a credibility assessment report.
And that includes any deviations from the plan.
This report may be submitted as part of regulatory submission included in a
meeting package or held by the sponsor and made available to
FDA on request, for example, during an inspection.
The appropriate approach depends on the COU and should be discussed with FDA.
Finally, step seven is to determine whether the AI model is adequate for the COU.
If credibility is not sufficiently established, there are several options.
The sponsor can reduce model influence by incorporating additional evidence,
increase the rigor of the credibility assessment, add development
data, or revise the context of use. Again, this is an iterative process.
It's not a pass/fail gate.
A question that arises in oncology, what happens when the AI
tool itself is a medical device? If an AI model meets the
statutory definition of a device, for example, a computational pathology
tool that analyzes whole slide images to aid in clinical diagnosis, which
we're going to talk about, which George referred to, or a
radiomics platform that assesses treatment response, that's
subject to a separate regulatory framework
for AI-enabled devices, which is based on, among other guidances, the
draft guidance, Artificial Intelligence-Enabled Device Software Functions:
Lifecycle Management and Marketing Submission Recommendations.
That was also published in January 2025 on the same day as
the drug and biologics guidance. This guidance, the device
guidance, covers a full total product life cycle from development through
post-marketing monitoring and includes specific recommendations on
device description, labeling, data management, performance
validation, and cybersecurity. So the advice to
any sponsors who are developing an AI tool that may be used in drug development,
you need to determine early on if the tool meets the device definition.
Model
risk. Sorry.
So both of the guidance documents are actually grounded in this idea of the
total product life cycle. This means that regulatory considerations begin at the
design phase and extend through post-market monitoring and ultimately
decommissioning. For oncology
AI specifically,
this is important implications, which we'll discuss in the questions, but
data drift, the degradation of model performance when real-world
inputs differ from training data, that's a particular concern in
oncology because the standard of care is often changing so
rapidly. New drug approvals, updated treatment guidelines, and shifting
patient populations can affect how a model performs in deployment.
So life cycle maintenance of AI model credibility is not
optional. It's actually really a core regulatory expectation.
I just want to also take a moment to talk about
these 10 principles across AI life cycle.
CDER and CBER, in collaboration with the EMA,
developed 10 guiding principles for AI use in drug and biologic development,
and this was published in January of this year, 2026.
This work reflects a shared international commitment to responsible
AI adoption in drug development.
AI can accelerate innovation, reduce time to market,
strengthen pharmacovigilance, and improve prediction of safety and efficacy,
but only if it's used responsibly.
Unlike traditional tools, AI systems evolve and interact with humans,
which introduces new risks that require structured oversight.
These principles aren't
prescriptive rules. Rather, they're meant to inform good practice and support
further guidance and harmonization among different regulatory agencies.
So I want to highlight four key principles that I think are especially important to
this audience and for our discussion.
First, transparency in model development and
decision-making processes. FDA does not require full
explainability of every model. We recognize that complex deep learning
models may not be fully interpretable in a way that is meaningful to end
users. However, we do require methodological
transparency, which I'll describe shortly.
Second, external validation using independent representative data sets.
We've talked about this, I think in George's presentation, he mentions this.
Test data must be independent of development data.
It must be representative of the intended use population, including across relevant
demographic subgroups, cancer subtypes, and
disease stages.
Third, alignment with good machine learning practices.
These are internationally recognized guiding principles that FDA has endorsed,
and they provide a useful baseline for any AI development program.
Fourth, early communication with FDA is
encouraged.
There are a number of regulatory challenges to consider.
The first is bias and representativeness.
The performance of an AI model depends heavily on the quality,
diversity, and representativeness of the data used to train and tune
it.In oncology, this is particularly acute.
Training data sets may underrepresent
certain demographic groups, cancer subtypes, disease
stages, and because oncology standards of care evolve so rapidly, a
model trained on historical data may
perform poorly
on patients treated under current protocols.
So this is data drift, as I mentioned before, and it's a serious concern.
For drugs and biologics, our guidance emphasizes that data used to develop
AI models should be fit for use, meaning both relevant and
reliable. These data should include
key data elements and sufficient number
of representative participants that reflect the target patient
population. A second challenge is transparency and
explainability. So this is an important distinction between
interpretability, the degree to which cause and effect can be understood
within a model, and explainability, the ability to
provide explicit justifications for model decisions.
As stated previously, FDA does not require full explainability,
but instead requires methodological transparency.
And that is the clear description of how a model was developed,
what data were used, and how performance was evaluated.
That should hopefully be achievable for any model, regardless of its
complexity.
The third challenge is data infrastructure, and I hope we're going to discuss some
of this during our talk, but standardization of clinical data across
institutions remains inconsistent.
Questions of data ownership, privacy, and security are unresolved, and the
field lacks public available reference data sets for benchmarking
AI models in oncology, something that we believe is urgently needed.
Just in terms of some path forwards, again, engage
early with the FDA.
Ensure robust validation across representative populations,
which we've talked about. Implement real-world
performance monitoring.
Model deployment is not the finish line.
Build monitoring into your development plan from the beginning and establish clear
triggers for when model performance requires reassessing or retraining.
Maintain transparency in model development and limitations.
Document your choices, your data, your training processes, and your known
failure modes.
This is actually what helps us at the FDA evaluate the model's credibility,
and it's what allows clinicians and patients to trust it.
And then finally, establish multidisciplinary teams consisting of
across the board people that would be involved in building these AI models and
using them. And then regarding ongoing needs,
this needs to be further development of public reference data sets for
oncology AI validation, continued harmonization
of our approach with international regulatory agency partners, and further
development of standard metrics for assessing AI tools across contexts of use and
clearer frameworks for data ownership and sharing.
Again,
just from a practical note, there's a variety of ways that
sponsors can engage with CDER and CBER.
These are actually detailed towards the end of the guidance.
And then, I just want to thank my colleagues at the
OCE, CDER, and CDRH, as well as past and present
colleagues. This is just a sort of a recruitment
flyer. We're hiring at the FDA, FDA oncology.
So if anyone's interested, feel free to
email futureofonc@fda.hhs.gov.
And then
these are some QR codes for the two different guidances I talked about, as well
as the FDA's Digital Health and AI Glossary, which is an educational resource
that's used online. We'll show these a little bit later as well.
But now I actually want to jump into
the discussion. So before we do that, I want to invite the two
other panelists that we have to introduce themselves, and then we'll
lay out the framework for the panel discussion and then go jump in.
So Carlos, if you want to go ahead.
Mic's on. I'm Carlos Sandy. I work in clinical data
management for ambulatory health practices, primarily EMR
implementations and data warehousing and reporting.
I am also a volunteer advocate for pediatric
cancer research and pediatric cancer patients and families, primarily through the
St. Baldrick's Foundation, and primarily involved in the
development of CAR T-cell constructs and improvements.
Hello, I'm Jacob. I'm an oncologist and AI researcher from
Germany.
In this year's ACR, I was on the program committee responsible for the AI
content, and I
put forward the perspectives that we should make the whole meeting about AI,
actually. But there was some pushback.
But we had a
good number, I think, of AI sessions and very exciting discussions
throughout.
I'm here today, I think, partly because I'm also an
ESMO officer. ESMO is our European Society of Medical Oncology,
which provides guidelines for
how cancer is treated across many parts of the world.
And we have published two AI guidelines last year.
George has kindly referred to one of them, and we hope to
contribute to this
regulatory environment by providing guidance from the perspective of
academic oncologists. Thank you.
Great. Thank you so much, Jacob. I appreciate that. And Carlos.
So we have about 35 or 40 minutes for questions.
We have a series of questions that we've developed for our own discussion.
But as we go through, and if you have any questions
from the audience as we discuss any sort of themes,
feel free to come up to the mic, and we can try to get you in.
We'll also try to get some questions online as well.
With our FDA, these discussions of regulatory science and
policy track,
and as has been discussed by both Jeff and
GeorgeThe patients are really at the center of all this, so I
want to start with some questions for Carlos.
If you can briefly discuss your journey to
patient advocacy, because that's all part of what brings you here and what
makes your experience so valuable.
You're at this intersection of IT health as well as being a patient
advocate with your two kids. So if you can give a brief discussion about that,
and then given your experience
and your own personal experience as a patient advocate, what do you think is
most promising of AI in oncology? What excites you? What concerns you?
Sure. As far as the journey towards advocacy, it
was a long, slow journey. I've actually had two kids with cancer, so the first
go-around was in 2006. I was not really involved in healthcare IT at
the time. We're billing systems, and my daughter had
very hard-to-treat AML,
diagnosed 16 months, died at 2 months, and that did not lead me to advocacy.
I tried to forget all about cancer for a while, but then in
2013, my then four-year-old son was diagnosed
with lymphoblastic leukemia, chemo-refractory.
He was fortunate enough, though, to be the 10th patient at
the first CAR T trials being conducted at NCI in Gaithersburg, and
it was successful.
He's 18 now and doing great. But the moment
was kind of similar to what's going on today with AI because we
were right there at the first clinical applications of an
entirely new modality of treatment with a lot of uncertainty, a lot of
regulatory uncertainty.
A lot of issues surrounding intellectual property and translating
this successful research into a widely available therapy for
people who need it. And 10 years later, it's kind of a
slow-motion rollout of what I think we're going to see with AI.
There's a lot of new discovery. There's a lot of
published results that aren't going to make it to translation for various reasons,
either due to the small size of the populations, lack of commercial
viability, et cetera. There's a lot of
parallel issues,
but this is going to be happening on a much larger scale across all the
cancer communities you can think about as far as patients and advocates go.
To jump into what excites me about this the most, it's really
options, right? When
you're up against the wall looking for a cure and something comes
along,
it's fantastic. And when you're
not quite to that stage and researching options, it's really good to know that
there's something
on the horizon.
What concerns me is it's just going to be so much to
sort through. And yes, you could say AI will help you sort through that,
but then
there's the practical experience of being a patient.
So what happens when
you are able to get on ChatGPT and ask about your condition?
You may be running out of options, and all of a sudden, you see that there's
32 prospective options, some of which have been proven, but
none of which are commercially available right then, and you've got a few months.
So,
I'm sure there's compassion use and all that, but
the
possibility is a lot of industry will be jammed up in the pipeline, and there's
going to have to be a lot of hard decisions about what moves forward and what
doesn't, and then do you let things go or sit on them until
they're profitable? And it's a lot of questions that I
can't answer, but the concern is just the ambiguity and the embarrassment of riches
and options.
Got it. Yeah.
If anyone else on the panel wants to jump in or respond to that, feel free.
Otherwise, one other question I had is, you've had experience in terms
of development.
What's your
thought about decisions being made or heavily influenced by an
algorithm in terms of
who might have a serious adverse event or whether a drug
would work? And what would you need to know in order to
trust that use of that algorithm? And this kind of goes into this question
of building trust.
I think I would still, even being sometimes above average
informed, want to rely on a provider who has experience using the
tools repeatedly and seeing results with the tools.
When it comes to algorithms, they use decision support algorithms all the time now.
Mm-hmm.
The concern with the rapid evolution is that a lot of these may be
relying on homegrown data, and so there may be variability in how those
tools, or how effective those tools are in different care settings and across
different institutions.
Specifically, when you're talking about SAEs, just looking at the current
landscape for conducting clinical trials and reporting
on SAEs, if you have a multi-center trial, you could see the same event coded
several different ways.
Mm-hmm.
And there's still going to be a lot of human variability in the underlying data
and maybe some false assumptions that because it's based on data, that
there's real consistency there that is being reflected in the outcomes
or the results.
Got it. Yeah, feel free to jump in.
And Carlos, this is such an excellent point because we have
challenges for
the deployment of predictive biomarkers, be them for efficacy,
toxicity, other forms of serious adverse events that
are human-caused. They are not caused by AI.
We have an opportunity, however, and I would like to rally this community because
we have an opportunity of going back to the biases, as Jeff alluded,
and Carlos, the interpretation biases as well, that have happened
for many decades. Technology has evolved in the lab in terms of the tests.
The interpretation of the findings still remains heavily
human-driven and at times very subjective.
Can we use these technologies to
actually-improve
substantially, a paradigm shift in terms of the reliability of these
tools with trust, with sufficient benchmarking and
evaluations that will actually ensure that what is
done in one medical system is interoperable with another medical system, that
the patients have real trust in terms of the assessment that's happening, and
actually that we can mitigate these biases that have been perpetuated by our
systems for decades, all of them
human-created. So I would ask all of us to
partake in this endeavor of reimagining the system through
technology now, because technology is going to be available to us.
It is what we do with it that will really matter.
To push back at that a little bit, where does the idea of the human in the loop
fall in? Because the way most people view human in the loop, it's sort of the
stopgap or it
keeps the trust in place. Is that something that's not really necessary,
or is it a different way that we think about human in the loop?
I'll let Geoff, and then I'll jump in as well.
Yeah, I was just going to say, I think there's some really
useful frameworks around this from the
perspective of autonomy, like autonomous vehicles and things like that.
And I was having a conversation with someone who
had worked with Waymo back in the day, and I think that they have a very
interesting approach to how do you develop autonomous vehicles, is how do you
define the domain where they're going to drive?
What are the conditions under which they can drive?
When is a human going to be operator going to evaluate it and not?
And at what point have you developed enough body of evidence that that
vehicle can operate in a way that's sufficiently safe, maybe beyond safe-
Better than a human
... better than a human, at which point it can be autonomous.
And so I think thinking through that field has pushed a lot farther ahead,
and I think part of that is it's more lightly regulated.
Self-driving cars don't have a huge regulatory apparatus around them.
And so I think that there's been some advancement in thinking about how do you
actually do this in a way that takes you stepwise to autonomy.
And so I do think that there are pathways to do that, but it involves, I think,
going through phases of when is the human in the loop, how do you know that you've
gotten to the point where it's beyond that, and then when can it be autonomous?
Sure. Yeah, feel free to jump in.
I think, again, we are crossing multiple inflection points.
In the last week, we saw the development of the first automated
alignment researcher that basically seeks to improve models
above and beyond
human, let's say, cognition and reasoning,
and in a way that actually we can measure the outcomes.
You can benchmark the outcomes of the automated alignment
research.
And
I think we have to think about what's the ultimate benchmark.
It's actually an outcome for the patient that's much better than what we can derive
through our insights today.
It's going to take time for us to get there.
For us to get there, that open-ended question, how do you deliver a better outcome
than we can derive today with heuristics, with our level of reason and
cognition, will require us to create all the
task-specific, end-to-end type of evaluations
that will give us sufficient comfort to be rendering those
decisions. To get there, we need extremely rigorous
validation of everything that we develop.
Without that validation, it's going to be really hard.
And the self-driving cars provide a really interesting framework.
That's a good analogy, actually.
Thank you.
To your point, this is an iterative process, and through every step of the
process, we need to ensure that there's
credibility and validation. Jakob, if you want to jump in
because you're at that forefront in the clinical trial space.
Absolutely. I think
evidence-based medicine has been such an important
achievement of humankind that we should
uphold it, right?
And it's not always
easy, and especially as patient populations
become much, much smaller, but
whenever possible, we have to...
For example, the dog guy, right, who made his own home brew RNA
vaccine. He gave his dog also anti-PD-1, and then
he observed some response. And what are you going to do with that, right?
So, did the AI actually help his dog or not?
There is no way we can tell.
And so I think we have to
probably uphold the lessons from the last century
about evidence-based medicine and try to
keep them sacred in this
time. Yeah.
You kind of talked about rarer and rarer populations.
You just hinted at it. And
so there's a lot of discussion about
AI for
data extrapolation,
including synthetic controls, digital twins, external controls, all to
support drug approvals,
potentially with much smaller traditional
trial designs.
To you, Carlos, how would you feel about a drug being approved based on,
in part,
on AI-generated evidence, potentially, rather than a conventional
randomized trial?
And what concerns do you have, and how do you maintain the statistical validity?
And part of that question also goes to Geoff, because you're a biostatistician by
training. So what's your perspective on that? So let's start with Carlos on this.
That's a pretty broad question. I'll try to limit it to one or two topics.
One of the things that was bouncing around my head as we were talking here is we're
going to keep coming back to, in this discussion, data breadth and quality for
when you're training models, making decisions.
And when it comes to
the last 10 years' worth of EMR data that's been populated
sinceThe big push in the ACA to get everybody digital.
There's varying levels of quality and objectivity in that.
A lot of what's in there
is there for expediency or antiquated workflows bleeding
into a new digital system.
And I think there's an opportunity to go back and kind of
over-read the last decade and draw some conclusions based
on the objective data that's in these large data sets
without focusing so much on just the structured notes, conclusions,
and things that people chose as far as conclusions.
And working that back in
parallel,
provider assistance tools that are AI-based are going to help
make the data that these kind of things are based on more reliable and give it more
objective context than just
what somebody thought. As far as would I be in favor of it, I mean, absolutely.
There's a lot of
rare diseases out there, including in my personal life, that you're talking about
two or three people a year that we know of that
have something similar enough to be called the same condition.
So not only is it appropriate in those cases, but I think the more
you start looking into AI-generated precision solutions for
medicine, the smaller your cohorts are going to get.
So I think that's just something that's going to happen naturally anyway, and we
might as well just get comfortable with it.
You go ahead.
The level of courage, Carlos, thank you.
Because I think
going back to that idea of having the patient at the very center of this
innovation-driven ecosystem, there's an opportunity for us to benefit patients.
As long as we develop these technologies for the synthetic data
generation that are trustworthy, why should we not
use it?
Sometimes you have no alternative.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Yeah, I-
Keep it to those hard cases first and then-
Yeah
... learn from it.
Expand.
Yeah.
Yeah, I would say from two perspectives, first of all,
really appreciate hearing that from a patient advocate perspective.
But then second,
from a perspective of an institution that's constantly struggling to meet
enrollment criteria on all of our trials, I think everyone is trying to accelerate
trial enrollment, expand trial enrollment, et cetera.
I don't think that this is a
common problem. And so as we think about that, if there are solutions to
that problem that can be developed from these AI models, I think
it's incredibly important value add for accelerating the
whole field.
Georgios kind of talked about step changes, and I think that's the opportunity
there. You go from, we're struggling to get
enough enrollment onto these trials, to we can synthetically do that at scale,
would be quite impactful. But the point that has also been made, and I think
it's really important, is what is the data that underlies
these models, and where do they generalize to?
And so I'm really excited about what's happening with these foundation models with
EMR data, but I'm also really excited about what happens when you have
counterfactual models. When you have models where you can actually say
something about, okay, this is what the response of this patient
was in the real-world evidence. But how do you actually predict what the
response will be under a new therapy or under an
adjuvant therapy? How do you make those sort of counterfactual predictions?
And I think there you have to go beyond just electronic medical records, real-world
evidence, to multimodal data, including genomic data, pathology
data, et cetera. And so I think that there's ways to do that, and then to
incorporate protein foundation models, et cetera, for new
therapies in that direction, or small molecule foundation models that are being
developed as well. So I think
there's a lot of development in that area.
And then it comes down to how well do all of those models
generalize to new cases? And how much are we recapitulating
what's in the training set versus predicting real de novo virtual
patients in new situations?
And I think that's where it comes back to the idea of how do we as a field
establish benchmarks that allow us to prove that that's true in a way that's
trustworthy kind of broadly and not just for individual use cases.
A quick question. Can you elaborate a little bit more on what you
touched on in the beginning about benchmarking?
Because I feel like, and as I was walking around and talking to everybody on their
posters, and everybody's trying their best to measure accuracy and everything,
but we always benchmark in a very specific use case, and then we apply in a much
broader case. And because there's no explainability in many of these models,
it's really a black box all of a sudden.
And so it would be great if we could have a little sticker on it.
Yes, this is always 90% accurate, whatever.
But
from an expert perspective, how would you approach this, and how do you
develop trust in those models once you apply it in an area where you
cannot actually measure accuracy or precision or anything like that?
Thank you so much. This is a super important question.
When we venture into the space of open-ended questions, we
can only benchmark as far as we know with
accuracy, but we can create guardrails.
And that's what some point that Geoff and I discuss very often.
Where you feel comfortable that your predictions can
add to what we do rather than blindly guide us to do
only that. It's actually at present, we are in the field where this can
enrich the realm of possibilities of what we can test
empirically. There will be a period where the number of
hypotheses that we'll have to test will increase until we generate the data
that's sufficient for us to develop trust in that space as well.
So it's going to be an iterative process.
At present,
for us, when we venture into the edge cases, really
edge cases, we have developed a series of benchmarks
with leaderboards of multiple different
models, and we create those leaderboards and interpret
in relation to one another as well, not only a
single
benchmark or a single model being tested against that
benchmark. So we calibrate in that way as well.
Sort of interesting to build on that point.
One of the really interesting challenges with benchmarking new
outside of training samples is that,
if you take, for example, an LLM and ask it to look retrospectively at clinical
trials that have already been run and say, "Predict the success of these trials,"
it'll do unbelievably well.
Mm-hmm.
But it'll do unbelievably well because the results of those trials are on the
internet, and you can-
Data leakage
... it's been trained on those results.
And so it's actually a remarkably hard problem to
set a benchmark for how these models perform out of sample.
One way to do it is if you have internal data that no one else has seen, and so you
can build benchmarks, which is, of course, I'm sure that's what's going on
with my colleague here.
Another way that we've been doing is
predicting the future. So in other words, we do prospective
validations where we say, "Okay. Here are 5, 10, 100
trials that haven't read out.
Let's have a leaderboard around what is going to happen on those prospective
trials where no one knows the answer to that question yet." And then we do those
evaluations prospectively. I think that there's going to have to be creative
thinking about that. And then going back to first principles, what data is in the
training set, how was the models created, et cetera.
You can kind of do some work in that direction, but I think the proof is really in
prospective studies. And I think I've started to have this
kind of concept that any foundation model in biology very much has
to follow the same path as a asset, a drug being
developed. The preclinical work, which is your internal representation
of it. There's your Phase I study, where you're actually testing it on a small set
of use cases that are very closely allied with it prospectively.
Then there's the prospective expansion to Phase II, where you're actually testing
efficacy. I think there's a kind of parallel path for AI development that there
is for-
Yeah
... clinical assets.
That's a great analogy, and you're really highlighting sort of the
view that we have to really be careful about the data sets that we use.
We have to have specific, separate
training data and then tuning data, and then eventually
testing or validation data sets.
Our benchmarks are actually trials that are not in the public domain,
that the data is not available in the public domain.
Mm.
So we can benchmark tasks that we know already and can
do a prospective...
Sorry,
retrospective testing of a prospectively accrued trial
where there's no data leakage. Yes.
That's how we tested the tasks that we understand
today. There's the realm of open-ended questions, predictions that have never
been made. For that, we'll have to generate additional empiric data in the form of
trials or cell line experiments or other types of data
that can help us increase our confidence.
It's going to be an iterative process. It's going to happen very quickly.
So to that point, that's
one sponsor or company doing their own sort of
benchmarking. You highlighted the need for third-party benchmarking.
How do we do that? Who leads the effort?
I don't know that that's within the purview of FDA per se, but we are
involved in some of these efforts, so I just kind of want to get your perspective.
You mentioned the NCI as well-
Mm-hmm
... and would love to get your thoughts, Jakob, especially being in the European
realm.
Yeah. Thank you. We will be happy to benchmark for you as
independent third
parties. Yeah. But
in my team, we are actually developing quite a lot of AI agents, and we are
always facing the benchmarking problem.
And one of the most important questions, I think, is what to benchmark against.
So if you have hard outcomes,
it's easy, right? But often you don't have that.
And for example, in my team last year, we published
and validated an AI agent for tumor board, so
it did pretty well. An agent system that had different tools, was able to solve
complex cases. We benchmarked it against human oncologists,
and it was basically on par. And when we've done a few
more of these studies as well, what we find is that
the humans are not the gold standard necessarily, right?
So you find that the humans actually hallucinate and-
Yeah.
... the humans do shortcut learning and the AI does too.
And sometimes it's on par and sometimes the AI is worse than some.
So it's-
What's the gold standard?
It's messy. It's messy, right? I think the only gold standard is hard
clinical outcomes. If you have clinical trials like these scenarios that were
discussed before.
Were the number of events different between two arms?
That's something that's hard and measurable.
But quite often, I think we're in a gray zone where you don't have that.
And benchmarking is from technical perspective an unsolved
problem. For example, in the tumor board case, sometimes the AI gets the
recommendation right, but then you find it never actually looked at the radiology
images.
Mm-hmm.
Or it got the recommendation wrong but looked at everything, or it
looked at everything too often and then got it half wrong
or half right. And so there's much more than just performance.
There's a lot to this, and that's an
unsolved
problem, but a very important one.
But Jakob, what's the ultimate benchmark for a drug discovery in clinical
development together?
Well, the ultimate benchmark is do you have a drug that
works perfectly like a CAR T cell in certain
leukemias, right? That's a hard benchmark, but that is so
far downstream. So the best benchmarks are
incredibly far downstream, and it becomes very hard to reach
them. So we have to have surrogate benchmarks along the way, and these
need to be defined.
One quick question for you. You do a lot of work in federated learning.
How does that play a role in all of this, in benchmarking and potentially creating
data sets that can be used
across different types of AI models and different
programs that can be used to
test and validate and potentially kind of create benchmarks?
Yeah, that's a great question.
There's increasing belief, I think, amongst the
data science and AI leadership of healthcare institutions
that the path forward to being able to do multi-institution
evaluations, both model development and evaluation, is through this idea of
federated learning.
Federated learning is a pretty
complicated concept, but there's a simple version of it, which is, let's say I want
to calculate the average height of patients at four hospitals.
I can just dump all the patient data in one database and average the heights.
Very easy. Another way I do it is I send a piece of code to each of the four
hospitals, and I say, "Give me the average height of the patients at your hospital
and the number of patients you used to calculate that." With those two numbers, I
can reverse engineer the average height of all the patients without ever having to
see all their data. So there's this appeal of being able to leave data where it
is, but actually calculate summaries.
You can do this for much more complex models as well.
So we've been developing this idea of how do you do this at institution scale
with something called the Cancer AI Alliance, which started with four cancer
centers led by Fred Hutch, and Memorial Sloan, and Dana-Farber, and Johns
Hopkins. And the idea is we all agree to
standardize our data to the same data model, do the same data cleaning checks
that were brought up just a minute ago, that these data are often very messy.
So we get the exact same data model at all four cancer centers.
Then we put it on a system where you can do federated learning and evaluation
across those data from those different cancer centers.
We did that with a lot of collaboration with technology companies.
And now the ambition is really to connect all
kind of cancer centers in the US and around the world on a similar platform, which
would make these kinds of evaluations much easier for real-world
evidence.
To a point we talked about just before we started here, that George can maybe
comment on the challenges then, not all the clinical trials are in that
data universe that we're putting together.
And so how do you think about incorporating that is, I think, a critical element of
what's coming next.
It's a critical element, Geoff, and you can see it in the performance of the models
without any fine-tuning, and with fine-tuning, with some
small sample set from our proprietary
data. But keeping a hold-out data set that's completely
ring-fence, completely separate to do the benchmarking.
So again, it's an iterative process. It's not magic.
It actually requires all steps to be taken.
And as Jacob said, articulating what are the surrogate
benchmarks and evaluations that need to happen along the way
is not a trivial task. It requires a lot of effort,
multidisciplinarity as well, because you need the experts,
people with domain knowledge and technical expertise working
together with the right infrastructure.
Without bringing that triad together, it's very hard.
And the infrastructure here, it's not only compute.
It's compute, it's data, it's the agentic
framework that provides the circuitry to connect the data with the models, with the
outcomes in a way that's not biased.
I'll open up to another question.
Thank you very much. Great panel. I'm Yinhua Mejuin,
oncologist from NCI.
I love the benchmark talks, but I will pull you back a
little bit to the regulatory pathway.
Mm-hmm.
Everybody's
using AI in their life.
At what time
our activity will be subject to
FDA's
purview? Like I use AI to select patient, I use
AI to schedule patient's calendar.
Mm-hmm.
I use AI to find out
how
difficult this patient will come back for follow-up, so I
do different approach.
Your
example is very classic, right? We have-
A straightforward example, yeah.
We
are doing a lot of different things.
When you say engage FDA
early,
as a researcher and PO,
as a sponsor, when should we have the click, like
Fred Hutch? All the activities you do, when does it
click in your mind? "Hey, look, wait, I need to check with IRB.
I need to check with FDA." That's my question one.
Question two is the human loop.
With all those great things, I would like to see what are
your opinions
get patients involved.
When we use AI to do research or research
AI device, how much are we getting our patient's
opinion?
Beyond
patient's opinion,
do our participants even know
what AI is used
and how, and what is related to them?
I would especially would like to hear the patient advocate
perspective. Do you feel you're included or not?
Thank you.
Do you guys want to start with the second question first, and then I'll come back
to the first question?
Thank you.
I think the second question was-
Yes, absolutely.
Yes, starting with the second question.
Why don't you go first, Carlos?
Okay.
Yeah. As far as the patient perspective, pretty much everything I've
been involved with signing
in complex consents has involved genomic data, and
I know what a genomic is, but I don't use it when I'm helping my kids
with their homework. So I think one of the biggest issues
we've faced with that is people think they know what AI means, but when you
put it in a clinical context, it may be a complete misperception or
another five pages on an 80-page consent that they're not going to read anyway.
So I'm a little torn by that. I think
everything that gets fed into research has some computational
analysisA little bit of magic of statistics and
variability among practitioners and how they use that data.
I don't feel it particularly needs to be disclosed as long as the ultimate
decision-maker is the treating physician.
Trust is what you-
Yeah
... rely on. Thank you.
From the perspective of
having the patient's voice as part of the decision making,
actually, in our strategy for AI, we have partnerships with
five different groups. Hyperscalers to give us
infrastructure from TAI labs, specialized AI companies,
academics like Jacob, Jeff, we partner very often,
but the fifth pillar is patient
advocates. We realize that without having their voice,
we may be developing solutions that are really not fit for their purpose.
So we wanted to understand what would be meaningful for them, first
principles. Second point, we're extremely impressed
with the degree of sophistication of some of the patient advocacy groups
in the development of AI solutions that help empower the patients
themselves. It was actually really humbling, and we will
welcome them as part of our ecosystem.
Thank you.
And to your first question, so, one, I
think the guidance does a pretty good job explaining what's within scope and out of
scope. So, really the only thing that we care about in terms of
regulation of AI use in drug and biologics
development is,
is the AI going to impact the data that we review, the
evidence that we review, with regards to safety, efficacy,
or the quality of the drug? If it has anything to do with even drug discovery,
it's actually like the guidance states that it's actually out of the purview of
FDA. We don't really care about it per se.
We're interested in it because it has an impact in terms of what gets moved
forward, but that's not really a question that we sort of ask.
So really the question you have to ask as an IND
sponsor or someone who's running a clinical trial, will this actually
impact the safety data, the efficacy data, or the quality data
related to the drug?
I'll just add on one extra layer, which is you also have to think about the IRB
component of that, that you brought up.
And so we've built an AI review committee that has a
cross-functional committee that includes people from the IRB, but also includes
compliance, security, legal,
data, et cetera,
experts who can... Because a lot of these things on the research side, on the
discovery side, can get really complex.
And so you have to think about it from a lot of different angles to get it.
But I think a lot of places are starting to do this.
We're not the only ones that are building these sorts of
internal controls around these kinds of things.
That's actually a great idea that perhaps a lot more academic centers or
places where the clinical trials are run should be incorporated.
If you want to add another question.
Thank you. Thank you all for the presentation.
I'm Dr. Miliziano from Gustave Roussy, and my question is more on
synthetic data. And
I wanted to ask, since I think it's a topic really interesting
specifically for rare disease, where doing a Phase III
trial is really difficult sometimes.
I wanted to ask you about the methodology.
I know that there are different kind of methodology to do so.
For example, you can use real world data that are then used to
emulate the control arm or create,
augmentate the real world data or completely create a synthetic ones.
I wanted to ask you on the
regulatory point of view,
if you think that one of these methodology is better,
in terms of acceptability for a future
potential control synthetic arm trial.
I can invite you guys to answer the first part, and then I can jump in to kind of
discuss the regulatory perspective.
I'll submit something. The methodologies that we have for synthetic data
generation today are the worst methodologies that we'll ever have.
Okay?
Agree with that.
Yeah. So it's evolving so quickly.
I mentioned at the beginning of my talk, yesterday we saw being presented
at the plenary, the first true multimodal virtual
representation of patients.
That actually has been presented openly, and the model is
available
externally through a preprint.
So that gives us a
new way of actually generating synthetic data now
as well. So it's a field that's evolving very quickly.
There are many different approaches, even if you use real world evidence,
if we're using feature extraction of that real world evidence or just
aggregating that evidence to create the synthetic data.
So do we incorporate radiology reports or radiology?
There are so many different ways that you can do it.
I think what is really important is for us then to measure how
much more we are deriving with the synthetic data.
With new approaches, we can generate a lot of additional information.
And particularly in the context that Carlos mentioned before, when we
have very small sample sizes, when we have very few individuals who
have that disease and mirror that particular clinical context,
synthetic data may be the old key.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I think just from a regulatory perspective, this is kind of a new frontier
for us. I think we can probably apply some of the principles that
we use when we're looking at real world evidence and real world data,
especially in rare subtypes of cancers where it's
just hard to enroll patients to clinical trials for that.
I think we really need to, from the real world evidence and real world data
side,
the evaluation framework is really principles of relevance and
reliability. So if you can demonstrate those,
that
data could then be viewed as supportive for clinical trial data that
we do have. And so I think our approach as we see more and
more of this come in and we can... view this data as trustworthy and
reliable, it's an iterative process that will help us at FDA
get more comfortable and provide more flexibility in that
framework. Right now, this is why I say
throughout my presentation, I said engage with FDA early.
Come in, meet with us, tell us your ideas, your perspective, how
you plan on using the model, how you plan on testing it, how you
plan on providing the credibility of it, and then we can provide
you feedback. And so, I think it really just depends on the context
of use as well. What is the specific disease
area that you're focused on, the rare subtype, and what's the treatment landscape,
and all of these things come into consideration as well.
Just the point that I made about being the worst technologies available.
The point here is that it's advancing so quickly, the methodologies are getting so
much better, that we'll be
in a position to utilize this much more intentionally
as we go forward. I'm extremely excited with this field because I
think it will help us
bring the solutions more effectively and
more quickly to patients.
We're kind of running short on time.
Maybe one more question. I'm not sure who was here first.
Can I? Oh yeah.
Go ahead.
I just want to ask a question. When these AI are ready,
is FDA thinking about those few years
ago, the 10 bound regional clinical trial only,
or the China cohort only, trying to get approval.
Is any thinking getting this ready
still? I know there is regional strategy, either Europe first,
China first.
Is FDA thinking about how do we accelerate it
using this tool to bridge the gap or shorten the approval
from the local
clinical trial, can get approval toward
other, like in the US or vice versa?
So just to clarify your question, are you asking about this from as an analogy,
or are you actually asking about how we can-
I'm asking how do you do it
... local trial.
Right. There's a China cohort.
Yeah.
Now the approach is we need to the clinical trial toward the
US or the rest of the world, like outside of China,
and test it, get approval. Can we skip or
shorten?
Yeah, I mean-
Not just like accelerate it.
Accelerate it, yeah.
Yeah.
To that point, I think it really just depends on the specific context and
situation.
I
could see a possibility where AI models are potentially used to
develop supportive data. I don't think it'll ever
replace the process of actually running a trial that's
multi-regional, if it's possible to do that trial.
The issue is that a lot of sponsors don't want to do it because it's
expensive or it's easier for them to run a trial, it's
faster in a particular region.
But I will say again, there's opportunities to come in if we want to talk about
model-informed drug development, if we're talking about finding dose
optimization.
Yeah.
There's opportunities for sponsors to come in and discuss these things
and discuss proposed methods
within FDA in that sort of framework.
We're about to wrap up, so I just want to ask a final question.
We definitely didn't have enough time.
There's a ton of questions that I had that we barely touched the surface on.
But just in terms of path forward, just a quick response from
everyone. In the end, how does the integration of AI to drug
development impact patients? And if you can identify one thing,
one policy change, one scientific advance, one shift in practice that would most
accelerate the responsible integration of AI to oncology drug development over the
next five years, what would it be?
We'll go around and then with you, Carlos, because we started with you.
So Jeff, if you want to start.
One thing is kind of hard when you've talked about all the stuff that we've talked
about here, but I guess just
guardrails is a topic that George has brought up, and I think is so important.
How do we set guardrails so that we can move quickly while
being confident that we're protecting patient privacy, patient
concerns, patient safety?
So, good guardrails, if I have to say one thing.
Thank you so much, Jeff. I would submit that the most
important point here is patient selection.
How
we make the solutions available to as many patients as possible, and then
offer the right diagnosis, the right biomarker, the right
treatment at the right time for the patient.
Clinical development itself can be transformed with AI.
It behooves us to do this safely, responsibly, but
at pace.
I would like to echo this, especially the pace thing.
So my hot take is just make everything faster, right?
If we can use AI to make everything 10 times faster, we get to
save lives because the progress
appears faster. And we don't need an AI scientist
that has superhuman performance that will discover things that a human would
not be able to. Maybe we will get there, but maybe not.
Even if technology stops and we succeed to just make everything much faster and
more efficient.
And I say this as a clinician who has
enrolled many patients in many trials, and it
increases your
hazard ratio of burnout and all that.
So even just the operational side is
very important. Just make everything faster.
Yeah.
And from my perspective, kind of blended personally and professionally,
super excited about this. I think it could help save a lot of lives and
avoid a lot of suffering.
I think we collectively need to rethink what we define as patient risk,
especially surrounding privacy.
A lot of what I see are silos and barriers
and uncertainty and wasted hours of people who could be doing better
things in medicine spent around avoiding a lawsuit rather than actually protecting
anybody. I know there is
historic reasons for that having evolved that way, but now would be a really good
time for a rethink collectively.
Awesome. So just in terms of sort of summarizing these last
thoughts, but the importance of guardrails and collaboration, but
really this effort to accelerate things and
because at the end of the day, it's really the patients that matter most, and I see
patients on a weekly basis. I see patients at the NCI and at
Hopkins in DC, and we really want to do best by
them. And so we have this immense opportunity ahead of us with this new
novel technology that could really transform how we treat patients, and so
we just need to do it responsibly.
Thank you everyone for joining us. Thank you to the panelists. We appreciate it.